Susy Schneider is the nuclear
disarmament program manager for pox in
the Netherlands she is the primary
author of the don't bank on the bomb
global report on the financing for
nuclear weapons producers which has been
produced annually report for the past
three years
she is International steering group
member of the International campaign to
abolish nuclear weapons and she
previously served as the International
secretary-general of the Women's that
our National League for peace and
freedom
Suzy sorry I hope it'll make you feel
uncomfortable Kolff I stand up it's a
little bit easier for me it's the after
lunch
you know after workshops my brain is
full with a lot of information some of
it is exciting some of it is a bit of a
downer
and I want to stand up and get my blood
going a little bit I'm also really
chilly so I like to move around so I
hope that's that's okay thanks is a
great introduction I'm really excited
that people are talking about the money
that is important money you know money
makes things happen and we're talking
about this this trillion dollar triad
but for me a trillion dollars doesn't
really make a lot of sense I can't see a
trillion dollars I'll never see a
trillion dollars all right maybe if you
will ever see a trillion dollars can we
hang out later but I'll never see it but
I do wonder like how do I make this feel
real to me so I want to think about a
little bit differently I wanted to throw
something out there at you when you
break down this trillion dollars over 30
years what we actually are talking about
is more than the normal US household
income per minute on nuclear weapons so
talk about sixty six thousand dollars
per minute on nuclear weapons
and that's a lot and that's a lot of
money we could do other things with and
we have to move governments to get to do
other things with that and that takes
time and it takes pressure and it takes
sustained effort and I'm so glad that
there are people here putting in that
time and sustained effort there's also a
lot of other interests and there's other
ways there's other ways we have agency
and power to deal with this money and to
deal with the money associated with
nuclear weapons raise your hand if you
have a bank account yeah
oh wow that's like everyone because just
about everybody does and we can use our
power as account holders to deal with
nuclear weapons and so I want to talk a
little bit about what it is that that I
do to help you to use your power as an
account holder so I create this report
don't bank on the bomb every year
and we look at a few key things we look
at the companies that are publicly
traded and are involved in nuclear
weapons programs so we look at last in
this last year's report 26 companies
here are their logos we put it all up on
our website and they're making the key
components now these are not guys that
are making screws you know these are not
guys I'm making toilets these are guys
that are making key components necessary
for nuclear weapons to be detonated okay
so these are twice it's companies we
update this list every year we do very
strict and I'm really a stickler for
detail very strict and a hard core
analysis and we verify and consult with
them to make sure their contracts are
current and when it comes to to nuclear
inspections sometimes we change the list
because a company will have ended its
contract and then we find out Oh company
changes its name Babcock & Wilcox sold
off part of its division to bwx tech
oh geez so we change and update our
information we want to make this
information as accurate and as usable as
possible for you the bank account holder
because a lot of banks have policies on
where and how they will invest your
money banks have policies insurance
companies have policies pension funds
have policies we look at those policies
we put together we call the Hall of Fame
right now our Hall of Fame is primarily
in Europe so we need to get some more
Americans going you know on this Hall of
Fame thing these are companies our Hall
of Fame our companies that have the
ultimate gold standard of policy they
will not put any money into any company
that has anything to do with nuclear
weapons all right these are great and
they they make sure they invest they
won't invest in the whole company so a
company like Boeing also makes planes
Airbus also makes planes these financial
institutions are Hall of Fame won't
invest in those companies they won't say
oh we but that we invest in good
projects like like new airplanes no no
they say the whole company is excluded
and this is important this is one of our
criteria and then we talk to these
financial institutions we say you know
what is it that you need to have a good
policy because we have a Hall of Fame
but we also have a runners-up in between
2014 and 2015 we added 30 new financial
institutions to our runners-up category
30 new institutions that say oh we'll do
something to limit our investment in
nuclear weapon production so something
is better than nothing
something means that they heard from
their clients they heard from people who
say I don't want my money to touch
nuclear weapons and they're at least
doing something and then we work with
them we say yeah well you know you did
something but it's not good enough so
you're not a hall-of-famer yet how can
we get you there
and last week we got to pension funds
the Dutch railway pension funds you know
they're gonna go in the Hall of Fame
because they added another company to
their exclusion list they said oh you
saw your report we didn't believe that
this company Moog had anything to do
with nuclear weapons but then we did our
own investigation we found out yeah
you're right will divest from them
immediately and we said great now we'll
be able to make sure that you're on our
Hall of Fame and a Hall of Fame we check
to make sure they implement the policy
and then of course we have a Hall of
Shame because you know you got to point
out who has investment it's important
for us to know who are who are the
people who are making this money
available you know who is it's in who is
it that lets the companies get these
loans that lets that puts these
revolving credit facilities who has
assets with these companies owns their
shares their stocks their bonds 382
financial institutions do most of those
are actually here in the US but they're
not only there for a bunch of other
companies other countries as well it's
actually uh yeah 27 countries overall
that there that are financial
institutions that are Hall of Shame and
we publish this list we put their names
out there so people know is my bank
banking on the bomb or not and it's
important because if you don't have the
information you can't do anything right
it's kind of key and then we help and
provide support as much as we can for
campaigns campaigns are awesome doing
something feels good doing something
about nuclear weapons feels really good
to be able to do something about this
and you know what it doesn't take a lot
of people we got Swedbank in sweden to
divest because we got one person got to
a journalist who was freaked out by how
many banks in Sweden were involved in
nuclear weapons and connected to nuclear
weapons got a front-page story and also
know these people posted stuff on that
banks on
Red Bank Facebook page saying what you
can't put nuclear weapons you can't put
my money in nuclear weapons we can't we
can't be connected with this no no no no
it's not Swedish we've got you know and
so in that band that you know one person
then within said Bank changed the policy
now they're they're pretty good really
excited that campaigns going on in the
UK the Royal Bank of Scotland in Germany
and Belgium and Sweden as I said in
Austria in Australia and we're you know
things are picking up here really happy
that things are also picking up here we
also have a little tool on our website
now I'm not a big technical person so
maybe there's some great technical
people who couldn't help us make this
tool a little bit better but we have a
little thing you can send a message to
financial institutions through our
website directly so don't bank on the
bomb calm and you can click on the send
a message and then you can send these
financial institutions directly just you
know put in your name and say oh this is
my bank I want you to get your money out
of nuclear weapons you can click to
tweet at them we've uploaded their
Twitter addresses and stuff like that
I'm a big person on Twitter I'd love to
do it and there's always an excellent
tool that I think some of you I have
some of you may also have GF banking on
your phone like you can check your
balance and stuff like that there's a
little icon generally little mailbox you
can send a message to your bank and ask
them a question you can do that right
now
there's free Wi-Fi here you can do it
right now and you can say do you have a
policy on nuclear weapons is my money
connected to nuclear weapons I don't
want it to be when you take that tiny
little action you start a reaction and
it's not a kind of you know fissile act
for some you know chain reaction but
it's a good one yeah and it's something
that that everybody can do and I hope
and encourage everyone to do and if
you'd like to learn more please get in
touch with me tweet at me call me
send me an email and I'm happy to talk
to you all and thank you very much great
thank you Susie well we have time for
just a couple of questions for Jonathan
and Susie yes
now we cannot be that easy who says a
lot of doable work is no Constitution
but it's just
Susie you have state-by-state listings
of nuclear firms operating across the
country and in turn we don't have the
capacity to put that together
we do however work a lot of other people
kind of information well we can't put
that together ourselves tell you why ask
Walt Havenstein who lost from the
governorship in New Hampshire its mr.
BAE oh yeah yeah and in 2014 he was
running for governor at the same time
the Scott Brown was running for the for
the Senate so what you had was the
military-industrial complex running to
run the state of New Hampshire so any
data we can get from anybody by way of
state-by-state breakdown smite helped
thanks a lot okay thanks
time for one more one more question yes
when you talk about companies that are
making nuclear weapons are you also
including companies that are
manufacturing the delivery vehicles we
talk about the warheads themselves a lot
of companies do both but because of a
resource brilliance resource restraint
we are limited in what we can put out
there there is you know we've had some
it's important to look at that
but we only can do as much as man the
Internet can do I just want to say
quickly that as individuals or whoever
we are I think we really need to target
both I know your constraints but also
anybody who has something that they
believe is a socially responsible
investment look again because it's
shocking what some of those funds invest
in we see we have a need in the u.s. to
have research come together and target
the military-industrial complex and the
delivery systems okay well thank you